butterflies beautiful it isn't that
crazy orange black like we love them
love them you find a spider you stomp it
you would never go to a zoo and go into
the moth house if you kill a ladybug
you're an asshole Oh completely your
type of person who kills ladybugs yeah
but if you don't kill roach I can't hang
out with you you let a roach run across
the kitchen floor you like satnaam Roach
satnaam I see him I'll kill that fucking
thing you got a roach in your kitchen
lady dots on it why are we racist with
bugs because there's such thing as
beauty okay that's why squirrels get a
pass and rats don't yes
bushy tail yeah we can kill style like
jacket matches the tail was just because
they found out if the tails grew bushy
people would stop killing them yeah I
mean what's more disgusting than just a
skin tail nothing on it
awesome Oh awesome tail puns don't even
cause any problems there just see us
sting possum tail yeah oh you fucking
get your bat will hands little hands and
your little reptile tail Oh little beady
eyes disgusting yeah but like we we have
certain animation that we'd like like
raccoons
look we don't rat coop like raccoons in
there eating out of your garbage but now
if someone had a pet raccoon you would
think that's the dopest thing ever
we have we secretly want relationships
raccoons if they would only be nicer to
us yes we would embrace raccoons
raccoons don't want to have shit to do
with us they don't I don't get it we are
smart what's your smart for us we're
nice to them though these people are
assholes
it's weights they go to sleep in either
trash let's just eat this fish savory
either garlic they put lids on it
doesn't work they've got that cool black
mass you lift the lid you throw it aside
you pull the bag out their hands I know
if people ends a little tiny people I
know we can grab stuff smoke cigarettes
hang out yeah the next they also kill
chickens well so do we do you know who's
a real predator skunks skunks or
predators there's a skunk living in the
back of my yard Oh
sprayed my dog oh no it's still there I
think so come on bro
man up what am I gonna do take out this
gun hazmat suit why you'd be gun time to
go to war
I gotta go crawl under the thing and
find him probably the thing go look at
this fucking hand yeah that's crazy
it's like he's flaunting he's like yeah
look at that
ah his hand is so much smaller than his
face it's crazy
imagine if your hand was that small and
relationship T's the size of your head
he's adorable though isn't he he is a
cute little fella it's like look at look
you think I've stayed out of your
garbage no way
look what I'm working with do they have
opposable thumbs but what I'm working
with didn't quite seem like now it looks
like five fingers yeah no thumb right
that's the thing they never figured out
look at his teeth they never figured it
out like they had meetings dudes we just
need a thumb let me see the teeth there
we go he's got his mouth open
oh you're that whoa that well that would
really are a fucking suck look one of
them's chipped if a yeah from biting you
in the head do you think if a racket
attacked you could fight it off no well
you could stop it would you do would you
give up it might cut your neck when
would you decide we're going to to the
death immediately immediately yeah you
wouldn't try to talk to raccoon out of
this no fuck off Suze makes a move I'm
ready now because I've been thinking
about it since childhood oh look at that
one I don't want that one bite my nose
yeah like a hyena no the raccoon and
made that thing I've been thinking these
things are coming after us my whole life
so if he makes a move it's on bro those
teeth are goddamn terrifying
yes look at those teeth now and they're
sneaky that's a big thing and they're
filled with rabies filled yeah to the
top like their balls are heavy with rage
it's just oozing out of them - water
balloons
raccoons swish senses touch Oh
raccoons rely on their hands more than
their eyes and going to touches that I
suggest that their sensitivity to touch
increases when their hands are wet which
might be why they always wash their food
why I just washed my hands and now I am
going to touch you when you sleep I'm
going to touch you and your children
where he was sleeping with my five
finger hand